russian cyber crime group is threatening
to attack anyone opposing russia's
invasion of ukraine conti announced on
its webpage that it would retaliate
against russia's opponents the group has
been blamed for numerous ransomware
attacks in the u.s and europe including
attacks on more than a dozen american
medical and first responder networks for
more on the cyber threats arising from
russia's invasion of ukraine we are
joined now by chris krebs he's the
former director of the u.s cyber
security and infrastructure security
agency chris good morning good morning
so as you know in the lead up to the
russian invasion of ukraine there have
been concerns
about widespread russian attacks we
haven't necessarily seen that though
what is your assessment of that
situation
that's that's absolutely right and many
i think in the cyber security community
are are surprised it should have been
part of the initial invasion by russian
forces to shut down internet and
telecommunications so that the ukrainian
people could not share what's happening
in the country and as president
zielinski said the truth is their weapon
and the iconic images the legends that
have been born thus far in the last 48
72 hours are all on the ukrainian side
and so i think the the russians have
made a strategic error now they still
have time and space to make changes and
lay down an information blackout or
blanket in the coming days but in the
meantime they they have made a mistake i
believe
chris how do you expect the russians to
adjust their approach at this point and
and does that potentially include
attacks cyber attacks against the west
well they have significant the russians
that is have significant cyber attack
capabilities they've they've used them
in ukraine previously they've of course
used them here in the u.s so what i
would expect is as sanctions and other
lethal aid support increases to ukraine
you may see ransomware attacks like the
kanti group has
indicated yesterday as well as if they
do increase attacks in ukraine you could
see some operational control errors that
allow the malware or other destructive
activity to kind of jump the rails and
get
outside of ukraine so every business
leader here in the u.s needs to be
prepared this is not business as usual
you have time there are resources
available the the us government has
launched their shields up campaign that
provides information and resources to
every american business so
the the idea here is be prepared uh
don't panic so how does this group uh
kantai how do they work within
uh some of the russian um government i
mean how do they work in concert with
the russian government
well this is a a key question and it's
not exactly clear whether they're
operating with the direct approval or
at the direction of the russian security
services i've i've long suspected it and
they somewhat confirmed it yesterday but
there has been some
operational consolidation
of these ransomware and criminal gangs
over the last several months and it's
possible that you know the russians have
developed a strategic cyber capability
that can do their work for them in a
deniable reversible way so it's possible
that that they could unleash the hound
so to speak using ransomware groups
okay chris krebs thank you very much i
think it's so interesting that he says
the russians he expected them to shut
down the internet
in ukraine and they didn't which is a
mistake for them i guess yes which is
why we're seeing some of these images
and videos over the past couple days